I'm Wildlife veteran pitzy today I'll be
answering your questions from Twitter
this is wildlife support
[Music]
from osmosis reads do hippos eat people
or just Chomp on them a bit hippos are
clearly vegetarian they only eat grass
so they won't eat the person they would
just mash them up which would still be
fatal but at least they're not going to
poop you out the other end at Megabite
PNG asks how do vets diagnose animals
like they can't even talk how do you
know but remember even vets that work
with domestic animals like dogs and cats
and horses they don't talk either but
they do show symptoms some of our
Wildlife patients are really tricky
because they hide their symptoms so if
you're a deer or a capybara or something
that may be eaten by another species you
will always mask your symptoms because
otherwise if you look ill I pray to tear
with it it's a tiger a line or crocodile
might single you out to catch you and
that means there's Wildlife it's we have
to be aware that if an animal looks
completely healthy it may still actually
be injured and a good example of seals
seals might have a big fight and one
seal might get a really bad crushing
bite from another seal but without
punctures to the skin it's invisible to
us so we can use a thermal camera and
that will tell us that there's tissue
damage or an infection or an abscess
forming and we can treat it quickly
before it gets too bad question from egg
salad screams why do big cats have round
pupils but normal cats have slit pupils
I think I sold to our tigers are cuter
than normal cats we know domestic cats
have slit-like pupils whereas lines have
around people now we don't really know
why there's this difference in cats
there are several theories and one of
them is that a slit pupil is much more
effective for nocturnal animals because
they can actually filter out much more
light so you will see seals who are
underwater will have a big pupil but in
the daylight can't damage their retina
will have a slit pupil and so will many
nocturnal cats but then lions are also
nocturnal so that doesn't answer
everything entirely there are also
theories about different wavelengths of
light being affected by the different
parts and the edges of the lens and that
has an effect on how the people works so
it's a good question because we don't
entirely know the answer yet question
from sux you peel I would not want to be
the one to put an oxygen mask on a tiger
for Tiger surgery hashtag no thank you I
don't blame you neither would I now
believe it or not one of the first zero
Wildlife anesthetics was actually a
cheetah in London Zoo in 1850 that was a
nether task not even with a face mask
but with a sponge with chloroform on a
long stick so the animal had to be
really sick to allow people to pin it
down with ropes and do that but then
we'd never do this today on a tiger or a
line instead we would use something like
a DOT to deliver the anesthetic drugs
into the muscle only when the animal is
really fully asleep would we either put
a mask or tube down to give them oxygen
and anesthetic gases at Blythe Renee
asks does the placebo effect work on
animals now that's a really interesting
one because we always think that the
placebo effect works on people because
they don't know they've been given a
placebo but animals won't know that
there's even this possibility of effect
however often there's a person involved
so whether the animals in a zoo or
rescue center being treated the thing is
that placebo effect may work with the
person so that even if it isn't a drug
that is working the person thinks the
animal's getting better however it gets
more complicated because there's an old
study that was done in Russia many years
ago where they took dogs and they gave
them cyclophosphamide which is a
chemotherapeutic drug which crashes your
white blood cells now they gave this to
the dogs in a very specific tasting
syrup and the white blood cells went
down and then they stopped and a few
months later they gave them the syrup
without this nasty drug in and
interestingly enough the body reacted
and dropped those white blood cells just
the same as if the drug had been in
there so even though the animal wasn't
aware that this medication was having an
effect on its body somehow the placebo
effect had this extreme effect in
animals so it does show you the placebo
effect is much more complicated than we
understand and we still have a lot to
learn about about it particularly when
it comes to animals right next question
is from atnari 31 it just came to my
mind and it is
confusing me up right now how do we know
the gender of a snake and how do we know
if a snake is a male or a female we will
use things called sexing probes so we
can hold a snake we actually insert
these right next to a snake's bottom and
run them just along the side the VIN now
a female would only have a very
superficial scent gland but a male this
will slip all the way down the hemipino
when we pull it out we can see it's gone
in quite a distance it's a male that's
how we sex snakes but we have to catch
them first at Max money asks how many
bones does a giraffe have in its neck
oh who knows well we do know and giraffe
have exactly the same number of neck
bones that we do they've just become
very long so giraffes neck bones are
about this long Elisa ah asks do vets
give animals pregnancy tests like how
would you know an elephant is pregnant
and this is an interesting question
because we need to tell if an animal is
pregnant in different ways depending on
how its reproductive cycle works so
orangutans and chimpanzees are really
easy we can just use some urine that
we've sacked up over the ground on a
human pregnancy test for an elephant the
hormones are very different sometimes we
need to collect feces and it needs to go
to a specialist lab and that can take
many days some animals like an elephant
we can actually do an ultrasound and
actually put our arm up their bottom and
do the ultrasound from the inside to be
able to reach anywhere because they're
thick corrugated skin will just not let
us get an ultrasound scan from the
outside at lady Starfire Ben age eight
would like to know how many teeth does a
crocodile have I can't count count them
but there are many and the reason is
that they will continue to shed and
erupt new teeth their whole life so
they're not quite as Extreme as a shark
but it makes sense if you're a Croc and
you twist you'll pray that you're going
to break and lose teeth and you have to
regrowing them but they have a lot more
teeth than we do real James coffin asks
what do big cats think of domestic cats
I'm sad to say they won't see them as
some sort of relative of theirs in any
benevolent fashion is there just a big
Predator that will see a small Predator
either as competition or as a potential
meal so I think if a domestic cat got
into a Target enclosure it would be
eaten really quickly at Bell 31W do
elephants from different parts of the
world speak different elephant languages
the short answer is yes but it's more
complex than you think just like in
people non-verbal communication is
important in all animals including
elephants and so that would be different
for the three different species of
elephants so it's an African elephants
Forest elephants and Asian elephants but
what we also tend to forget is that
elephants also communicate through
infrasound which is really low frequency
sound and that carries over a very long
distances so elephants very far away can
actually hear that poaching is going out
in a different part of the country
because the elephants in that part that
have been poached will let out these low
frequency rumbles we can't hear but
elephants close by can actually hear
these sounds through their feet as well
so elephants almost have ears in their
feet that will pick up part of that so
we don't understand enough to know
exactly what is different but watching
elephants interact in places like zoos
from different parts of the world do
tell us that there are some differences
in how they communicate with each other
rigatoni asks why do giraffes have
antennae now I can understand why you
would say this because they have these
two lumps on top of their head that are
covered in hair but they're actually
horns and they use them not so much to
fight but from Evolution that was their
purpose giraffes now fight by banging
their necks together and so because the
horns don't Clash Evolution has seen fit
to mainly cover them with fur at
defeating labels asks why do I find
snake surgery so interesting so I guess
you find snake surgery so interesting
because it's just such a different body
shape they've got one long body cavity
with all the organs spaced out in it and
they've got no limbs but probably even
more interesting than the actual surgery
is how we safely get hold of some snakes
and for that we often use a snake hook
you may see this being used to either
scoop up a snake safely and put it in a
bag or a tube so we can use anesthesia
but sometimes we'll actually use this to
pin a snake down on a giving surface but
there is a trick to this we actually are
pinning the snake's head itself down and
never its neck because unlike us snakes
actually have a really really weak
Junction between their neck and their
skull they only have one little
articulation there whereas us and most
mammals have two so we have a much more
sturdy connection between our skull and
our neck and Gregory asks do you know
why they say an elephant never forgets
elephants obviously have a huge brain
much bigger than ours now part of that
is to control this unique appendage
they've got called the trunk but they do
have phenomenal memories and I've seen
elephants that
Cameron lived in a zoo and 40 years
after they've come from Myanmar where
they were used as a logging elephant
someone has come up to them and suddenly
started to give them the old commands in
Burmese and the Elephant takes a few
seconds and suddenly oh no I need to
lift my foot 40 years later they still
remember everything that they learned in
a different country that shows you they
really do have a good memory at Meadow
Brick Road asks how quickly do big cats
closest analog to dromosaurs kill people
usually now that's a question that I'd
really like to deal with but if you were
to startle an animal had an Animal
Escape like a tiger a line the answer is
very quickly these are top predators
after all dazzo B asks how is it 2022
and we still cannot fix the broken leg
on a racing horse now the tricky thing
is it doesn't matter how high-tech we
are with its people or animals we can't
fix everything people can't live forever
and neither can animals and not every
injury is fixable but it is a particular
problem for racehorses and also for my
patients like zebra because of how their
legs are designed they're designed very
long with all their leg muscles at the
top of the leg so they have this long
leg that's very efficient for fast
running but that does mean that if the
leg gets a break at the bottom it is
basically just bone with a little bit of
skin covering it there isn't a very
robust blood supply and a traumatic
break over there with bone exposed it's
almost impossible to get to heal because
there's no soft tissues to protect those
bones at Mr Cruz I get to participate in
a surgery on a line this morning at Big
Cat Rescue and I'd like to know how to
control myself right now it's all too
easy to get tunnel vision into how
exciting it is and to forget to work
safely I know this only too well because
I once had a tiger wake up on me during
the operation and raised its head and
had a look at what I was doing and
that's a bit of a scary moment that
should never really happen in most cases
Chris hems asks how did elephants trunks
evolve the trick is to go and look at
animals that have something maybe
slightly similar so if you look at a
tape here you'll see a Tapia has quite a
long nose that it can move and sniff and
that's probably how elephants trunk
started they're a portion of their front
lip and nose that has become elongated
over time because they could maybe sniff
things out and then it became useful for
holding things and over millions of
years that portion of the front lip and
the nose has elongated into this amazing
organ the trunk of all its complex
nerves and muscles and everything in
there a question from Avril WP how would
you anitat as a giraffe now the tricky
part about the giraffe is actually
waking the giraffe up because the
biggest risk is the giraffe with that
very long sensitive neck and legs it has
to fall down if you Anita ties it and
then it has to get up without being
unstable enough and if you wake up from
anesthesia always a little bit unsteady
to not come crashing down again and
break your neck or your legs so often
when we move giraffes in the wild in
southern Africa we don't fully
anesthetize them we will Dart them given
in the anesthetic drugs and just before
they woozy enough to fall over we will
actually put ropes around their legs and
then we will actually reverse some of
the anesthetic drugs and then they sort
of partially wake up and we can walk
them into a very long box on a trailer
and we can move them to another National
Park or do minor treatment so the trick
is if we don't need to anithata giraffe
we don't m m Jacks asks do big cats purr
I bet it sounds like a Harley it can
sound quite loud so if you sit next to a
cheetah that's in a rescue center and
they purr it can be very loud much
louder than your cat but what's more
interesting than purring is actually
roaring that is how we classify big cats
versus other cats some surprisingly
large cats can't rule so things like
cheetah are not classified as a big cat
because they compare and they can meow
but they don't actually have the voice
box to rule Lord Christine asks why do
pigs have curly tails and presuming they
mean domestic pigs because most of the
wild pig species whether they're
babarusa or warthogs or colored peckery
actually have normal tails that will
cover their bottom and that's really
important because Bill bottom is a very
sensitive part to the body flies could
attack it or another animal could bite
it so your tail is quite protective now
water trucks will raise their tail when
they're running away so they can follow
each other and you'll see a mom wardrobe
doing that but domestic pigs curly tail
is something that we've probably bred
them for because a long tail when you
keep farm animals quite close together
and they tend to have squabbles they end
up biting each other's tails and with
pigs what will happen is that infection
will spread up the Tails into their
spine and they'll end up paralyzed so
over hundreds of years Farmers have bred
out domestic pigs to be really different
to wild animals and one other thing is
to have a small curled up tail that is
out of the way from being bitten so it's
not a natural thing it's something that
we've selected animals ourselves to have
for our own purposes DNA hilly Grace
asks do big cats like tigers and lions
cough up hairballs do they lick
themselves clean the same way house cats
do I'm just imagining a big old lion
hunched over hacking up the biggest
hairball I've ever big cats definitely
groom themselves just the same as
domestic cats most of the time though
they've got a big stomach and a small
amount of hair they're grooming after
every time they have a meal and that
just disappears out in the poop and it's
only very rarely they bring up a
hairball thank you for watching and
that's it from Wildlife support